foreign
[Music]
you want to set us up what are we doing
what are we doing here uh well this is
the first time the three of us have been
on a pod so at least come on I think
three or four times somehow you've never
been here during during those even
though y'all are friends you know each
other and uh that's just strange to me
but I think this we'll see how this goes
I mean I think this will be fun the
three of us here I wanted silly to come
on because
there was a whole bunch of
like rich people smart people [__] that
was going on over the weekend there was
the Silicon Valley Bank disaster Bank
Run all that good stuff there's stuff
going on in the stock market and so so
is the guy I go to whenever I have
questions I said all right well just
bring them on the Pod instead I'll ask
you the questions here instead of just
uh texting or calling and so that was my
that was my idea did you guys did you
guys get impacted by this at all I had
money in Silicon Valley Banks through my
uh my fund uh so our our Venture fund
had money through Angel list Angeles
keeps all their money
or kept all their money in Silicon
Valley Bank and so we were lucky that I
started hearing about it and I was like
yeah I think we should get out and uh
and so we ended up we had like 1.5 or
1.6 million dollars in that account
um maybe a little more actually because
they hold some for management fees and
then we got it all transferred out to a
bank I've never heard of they were like
you want to move to grasshopper bank I
was like you could put it in the [__]
field outside your office you know you
can put it anywhere just don't leave it
in the bank where they're where it's
like a bank run is going on yeah
uh so we got we got out like literally
in the nick of time
um so yeah we were almost impacted but
not not in a like major major way like
there were some people that were stuck
tens of millions or even 100 million
dollars so I'm sure you heard some crazy
stories like what did you hear I how did
it play out from your perspective yeah I
was at this SV Angel uh founder event
founder Summit in San Francisco on
Thursday when the bank run was happening
and
um people all around me were on their
phones trying to take all their money
out of SVP and transfer it uh and people
walked out of the sessions and were
sitting on their laptop trying to do
that
one guy told me that he wired 70 million
dollars out of his SVP accounts that
morning into his personal Morgan Stanley
account because he didn't want to wait
for
a bank account in the business name to
open because that would take 24 48 hours
which literally in normal circumstances
that would be maybe not illegal but a
hugely frowned upon definitely
ill-advised yeah it looks like you're
about to steal 70 million dollars of
other people's money and put into your
pocket but I think the people right away
was it like let's see what happens
because you know the the series of steps
was I saw the stock price go down that
was the first text I woke up to Sam in
our group chat somebody who showed the
stock was down 30 or 40 percent
and it just seemed like a stock problem
it seemed like oh the company is you
know getting hammered but like dude I
feel like I've seen that five times in
the last you know five months it was
something 40 but then somebody was like
oh yeah
could this mean that the bank goes under
and then the wheels started turning in
my head and fortunately I had seen I had
seen and not acted on two crypto like
Bank runs in the last year and been
burned by those so my I'm a criminal
under under reactor I don't really react
even in cases of emergency which is good
because in normal life usually things
are not an emergency and it serves me
well but when there is an emergency I'm
also pretty laid back and so this time I
I was I was smart enough to be like hey
we should do something right now don't
wait don't wait to see how this plays
out there is no upside in waiting to see
how this plays out did people recognize
it right away where you were absolutely
like hey there this could trigger a bank
run yeah and I think in the beginning of
the day no everyone was kind of chill
about it but uh a ton of VCS I think
starting with Peter Thiel said to their
portfolio companies if you have money in
svb take it out and take it out
immediately like right now do whatever
you need get it out of svb and let me
explain I'm the least educated on
finance stuff here so let me explain
from a five-year-old's perspective what
happened here so basically Silicon
Valley Bank it's like the 19th largest
bank in America something like that top
20 16th 16th and uh it's usually used by
Silicon Valley based startups and other
people who related to startups and so
what happened was during 2021 22 when
VCS were going crazy and startups to
raise a huge amount of money they used
Silicon Valley Bank so they took on tens
of billions of dollars of new bank
accounts uh but the and so they had all
this new money and so what they did was
they bought long-term bonds that yielded
a rate of like 1.5 percent which in a
way it was them thinking like we're just
going to be conservative and like and
not do anything crazy here with all this
extra money then fed increases the rate
to three and four percent and their
customers which is startups with new
cash are burning tons of money and
lowering their uh deposits or their
their savings and checkings accounts and
then it became uh public on Wednesday
stay at the quarterly earnings at the
earnings report that they said um we
bought these 1.5 bonds which is not good
because the FED recently raised the
rates to three and four percent which
means our 1.5 percent long-term bonds
are now devalued we have to sell a bunch
of them at a huge loss people heard
about that social media went crazy VCS
tweeted get your money out immediately
everyone starts pulling their money out
and then by Friday uh the FED set or the
government steps in and says uh we gotta
stop this they're gonna run out of money
this is not good everyone's gonna get
hurt is that a good summary of from a
from a from a dummies perspective of
what happened
yeah I think that's pretty good
um I think that all of those things
could have happened except if you know
Silicon Valley is just such a
um insular place but also such a viral
place where everyone talks to each other
so I think if it wasn't for the fact
that it was
Silicon Valley and everyone talks to
each other there wouldn't have been a
bank run this fast like
[Music]
um
on Thursday when the bank run happened
42 billion dollars
people try to wire out 42 billion
dollars in one day out of Silicon Valley
Bank how much money do they have 100
billion they have something 200 yeah
something like 180 billion dollar in
deposits so that's 25 25 cents on every
dollar was tried to be wired out in one
day and what happened when people tried
to do that it just said uh no I mean
what was the what what did they see on
their screen in the beginning of the day
it was working so uh this guy wired out
70 million dollars a bunch of other
people at that SV Angel event were
wiring money out no problem uh come the
afternoon they couldn't log in to
Silicon Valley Bank so it just wouldn't
let you log in in fact I tried to log in
yesterday I have a Silicon Valley Bank
personal account and it also said uh you
can't log in until Monday
because you've I know in the past your
companies use Silicon Valley Bank I
think you you raised money from them so
first were you affectionate and second
why does everybody use Silicon Valley
Bank uh I think they said 50 this on
their website I don't know if it's true
but fifty percent of venture back
startups
um used Silicon Valley Bank that's crazy
is it just the brand or did they do
something that that was like
advantageous to startups yeah they do a
couple of things so one they have strong
relationships with all the VCS
um and or so they thought yeah so they
thought so they've they've had strong
relationships with everybody so all the
VCS are like doing their own banking all
the lp all the Venture funds are doing
banking at Silicon Valley Bank already
and then
they host tons of events around Silicon
Valley and sponsor tons of events so you
just see their brand name everywhere as
the bank that you should use
um and it kind of has like an elite Vibe
a little bit which is yeah stupid
because or that's not stupid but the the
a lot of media headlines were like Bank
used by the rich and famous or Tech
Elite is going under and so the
sentiment was like ah screw them which
maybe that is partial part the reality a
lot of rich people do use them but like
payroll companies use them and when you
there was a lot of companies like
Rippling that the hustle used for
payroll years ago where you pay your
payroll to pay your employees Rippling
is the inner is the middle man they hold
on to your money for three or four days
and then they pay your employees
Rippling used them and so three or four
hundred five hundred thousand employees
of companies both blue collar and white
collar weren't going to be able to pay
their bill or weren't going to be able
to receive their paycheck uh so it's not
just like you know the elite yeah it's
kind of the name's a little bit of a
misnomer for whoever presents
yeah the other reason we use them at
tinico and this might be my greatest
Personal Achievement was I got uh free
tickets to the NBA finals uh from
Silicon Valley Bank where they invited
me to hang out in their box and watch
the game so uh you know there's a bunch
of perks like that for using Silicon
Valley bank and then also if you raise
any debt they're a huge Venture debt
provider in Silicon Valley so oftentimes
when companies will raise an equity
round uh they'll also raise a little bit
of debt so they'll raise you know 10
million dollars of equity
and three to five million dollars of
debt sometimes depending on kind of what
their Capital needs are and so when you
raise debt from Silicon Valley Bank they
require that Silicon Valley Bank is your
exclusive banking provider so all of
your deposits have to be at Silicon
Valley Bank as well that way they've got
visibility into it and that kind of
thing so a ton of startups will get debt
and then they have to use Silicon Valley
Bank as their bank so they have no other
choice and over the weekend basically
there was a bunch of people we have a
bunch of our mutual friends where they
were just like sitting there Friday to
Saturday and Sunday morning thinking
I think I just had all my money's gone I
don't know what's gonna happen I was
with like maybe a dozen people and
they're like you know I've had hundreds
of thousands or tens of millions of
dollars I just don't have that and I
have no idea how I'm gonna pay my
employees I don't know what's gonna
happen a Sunday night we find out that
everything's gonna be fine the the
corporation Silicon Valley Bank is going
under if you're a stockholder in that I
think you're going to lose everything if
you're a bondholder in that company I
think you're going to lose everything
but if you're a depositor if you're a
customer you're going to be made whole
and so it's no big deal I think you can
access your money now uh is that right
is that how this is currently being
resolved yeah that's exactly right so
the Federal Reserve and
um U.S treasury Department were like if
Silicon Valley Bank depositors lose
their money this is going to create a
systemic risk that systemic risk is
everyone who has money in these 2 000
local Community Regional Banks
is going to take their money out Monday
morning because they're afraid that
their personal bank will have a bank run
also so which would this is literally
what I've grown also right like anybody
being proactive would be triggering
an actual bank run across many many
other Banks and so they had to they had
to basically get people to chill before
Monday morning yeah exactly like First
Republic Bank is a bank that I use and a
ton of other startups use and in fact
First Republic Bank provides is the bank
that Mark Zuckerberg uses to get loans
for from for buying a house or just
getting a loan against a stock
um and there were rumors over the
weekend a bunch of my finance friends in
New York texted me and said hey do you
have any money at First Republic Bank if
so get it out Monday morning well so
today it's down 65
so even though this happened uh why is
it still down so bad
I think people are just still afraid
that there's gonna be uh that depositors
are still going to take money out of
First Republic Bank there was a funny
there was a funny um headline and it
said that um you know when you think of
this you think of like literal
pitchforks and like guys wearing straw
hats and like torches standing outside
of the bank because there was like a
headline that says people are rallying
outside the bank just banging on doors
to get in and you think like you know
like a pitchfork mob and it was really
it was like eight or nine like Asian
guys wearing Facebook book bags and like
North Face sweaters and they and they
were smiling at the camera like this
this article like they look really happy
they're like waving at the camera uh and
I saw that because it was a pretty funny
thing
well I think that was part of the
problem here was like like you said in
Silicon Valley everybody's so tightly
networked that like Words spread like
wildfire and then back in 2008 when the
global financial crisis happened in the
the sort of the other bank failures
happened there wasn't really like like
Twitter was very new at that point in
time smartphones had only come out that
same year so it wasn't like as fast so
this was basically like a bunch of
people who are all incestuous and all
talk to each other a ton on top of that
you can now do online banking and just
quickly log into your phone or your
laptop and wire out 70 million dollars
you don't even need to go to the bank
like normally it's like Bank Run there's
going to be a huge line and that huge
line itself is a like barrier to this
happening but in this case everybody
talked about it everybody moved it out
digitally and word started spreading um
you know basically fear started
spreading across Twitter Tick Tock and
other places and it just felt like it's
the end of the world uh you know move
now and that that sped this whole thing
up up into a one day
like tsunami Financial tsunami that that
hit
um what do you think about like it's
crazy because the I bet the CEO of
Silicon Valley Bank woke up Thursday
morning and was like what's the big deal
guys this is gonna be fine and uh was it
a big deal silly like besides the the
fear was it actually that big like was
the was the business itself at risk
um there is some there's a real problem
with the Silicon Valley balance sheet uh
because of the the sort of depositors
taking money out in general so even
before Wednesday
um because of all of the startups that
because the startups are the ones that
bank at Silicon Valley Bank they were
withdrawing money every week to pay
payroll and uh because of their burn
rates
um so there was already a problem but I
think that you know Regulators are
monitoring bank balance sheet on a
monthly basis very closely
so they were like this is all fine uh up
until that point and so nobody thought
this was a problem like the Silicon
Valley Bank CEO was like this isn't a
problem Regulators thought this isn't a
problem yeah but he had one line that
was bad he goes I we don't panic I think
he said Don't Panic exactly he did such
a terrible job of PR and um the way that
they came out on Wednesday and said hey
we're going to raise 1.8 billion we are
going to raise two billion dollars
because we lost 1.8 billion dollars like
they just mismanaged this from a PR
perspective and I think if they'd done a
better job of that they wouldn't have
gone
wouldn't be dead today and to to um
Sean's Point around just the speed of
this happening so the biggest bank
failure in American history is
Washington Mutual in 2008
and in 2008 10 17 billion dollars was
removed from Washington uh withdrawn
from Washington Mutual in 10 days and in
Silicon Valley Bank it was 42 billion
dollars in one day on Thursday so just
the speed with Which business happens is
like you know so much faster now and I
want you I want to get your reaction to
two people so Peter Thiel some people
are like oh Peter's teal strikes again
he's the you know this guy's the Menace
and then they're like he brought down
Gawker he got Trump elected and now he
he triggered the bank run of silica
Valley Bank so Peter you know do you
think that that's uh is it is there is
there any truth to that and then the
other side is Mark suster who's another
VC down in La who basically came out
during the process and was like this is
like like you should companies you
should keep your money there support
Silicon Valley Bank it supported us uh
there's you know we don't have to have
this hysteria if we don't do the bank
run there's there won't be a bank run
I'm you know keep your money there and
if you know for people who had listened
he could have
caused them to basically you know lose
or lose access to the majority of their
money so what do you think about those
two people and where do you play place
the sort of how much blame or credit do
you do you give to those people
uh I do think Peter Thiel has a ton of
power he's like this Godfather of
Silicon Valley uh you know we had a tiny
cowboy and Mark Andreessen on our board
and he would never mention what anyone
else says except he would constantly
mention what Peter Thiel says so I think
what's an example
um and why
uh I think he just Mark Andreessen I
think just looks up to uh Peter Thiel
and thinks that Peter Thiel has a bunch
of good ideas
um so for example one idea of what one
thing he I remember him saying was
um Peter Thiel says the best startups
have one source of Revenue
uh not eight sources of revenue I'm sure
you've seen this in startup pitch decks
where they're like we're going to
generate revenue from ads plus we're
going to generate revenue from
businesses plus we're going to generate
revenue from these customers
um to having like eight different
revenue streams is much worse than we're
Facebook we're going to generate revenue
from ads one single clear Revenue Source
in the beginning
and and do you think that I mean I don't
think he's the bad guy in the situation
because basically what happened with him
was uh it'd be like if I'm just a normal
person went to the bank account and they
tried or the ATM they try to withdraw
money and the ATMs glitching and they're
like
this doesn't feel right hey family uh I
think you should bounce and go get your
money out of this this is like glitching
this does not look good because I
believe Peter Thiel he did a CAT I think
Silicon Valley invested in Founders fund
or something like that uh is that the
story or he did some type of capital
call uh and Silicon Valley could didn't
pay up right away is is that right uh I
didn't say anything about that
um and uh yeah I don't know what that is
what I know is that he basically Peter
Thiel was the was one of the people in
Silicon Valley that was like this is not
good everybody take your money out and
then you know all the other Venture
firms heard that and sent emails to
their portfolio companies saying the
same thing like on Thursday you know I'm
an invested in a bunch of venture funds
a bunch of them
emailed their LPS and said hey this is
our exposure to Silicon Valley Bank as a
fund
we're talking to all the portfolio
companies and trying to get them to
remove all of their money out of Silicon
Valley Bank so really they caused the
bank run you're you're an LP in like
you're an investor in a bunch of funds
uh like maybe what like 15 or so big
Venture funds uh yep did they have their
money tied up and I'll ask I'll tell you
why I think this is
something was a little fishy here so
on that Thursday or Friday when it was
all going down
um VCS were simultaneously telling their
portfolio companies hey get safe but at
the same time we're basically saying hey
the FED needs to come in and ensure that
all the deposit depositors are going to
be made in whole
um
and they were saying it anytime somebody
uses the like what I call like the
single mother story it like makes me
very suspicious and what I mean by that
is they were like you have to do this
because jobs are at stake these
companies have to make payroll and if
they can't make payroll next week you
know this is going to cause jobs to be
lost and you know who works those jobs
single mothers and like they basically
was all about payroll small businesses
jobs saying all the political like
buzzwords to get like Washington to do
something because you know nobody wants
to go be like hey I'm a venture fund we
had 90 million dollars in Silicon Valley
Bank because they gave us lines of
credit and we were we had to keep our
money in there and we're stuck you know
we're way above that FDIC limit and if
we're not made whole we're we're screwed
um was that the case or is that just my
conspiracy should I take off the
conspiracy hat or or is that do you
think was that a part of it yeah I mean
I I saw a bunch of videos of David sacks
and Jason calcanus and stuff saying that
kind of thing I my I'm skeptical that
any of that matters I think the way that
um Jay Powell and Janet Yellen look at
this is uh there is a systemic systemic
risk to the banking system so you know
taking a step back from Silicon Valley
Bank like the met the American Financial
system is this amazing black magic
that exists and it is a source of
tremendous amounts of prosperity in
America and in the world like if you go
in places like Pakistan where I was born
you don't have a
um you don't have access to a credit
card you don't have a FICO score you
don't have uh the ability to go get buy
a piece of property and get a 30-year
mortgage on it that the government
backstops
um
you are constantly worried about the uh
your currency being inflated because
you're not sure that
um the the government is gonna isn't
gonna just print so much money that your
rupee that's worth uh 100 rupees is
worth yeah your life savings basically
disappears because of inflation
and you're not worried when a company
that's a publicly traded company reports
earnings that those are lies in the
United States like there is so much
stuff that is amazing in America from a
financial infrastructure perspective
that the rest of the world does not have
and the Federal Reserve coming in and
bailing out Silicon Valley Bank
and doing it without using any taxpayer
money making all the depositors whole
wiping out all the equity holders wiping
out all the unsecured debt holders
like that's the right thing and where'd
the money come from yeah if it didn't
come from taxpayers which is that 25
billion back to that come from and also
bailout I don't think it's the right
term because they didn't bail out the
bank the bank is out of business or or
it's dead but they bailed out the
depositors right the customers
yeah and and you know what people were
saying on the internet single mothers
yeah yeah because they need that third
home in Truckee
yeah what people were saying on Twitter
which I agree with is that hey when you
put money into a bank you're not
thinking of this as buying um a risk
asset you're just thinking of it as I
literally have cash I could store it
under the mattress but that would be
silly I'm gonna store it with the bank
and the bank is going to do a better job
of taking care of my money than me by
storing it under my mattress and that's
an important American value yeah
that is a super important American value
that is my product that the banks sell
yeah it's Safety and Security faith that
you are your money is safe and if that
product
if they if people start to question that
the banking system doesn't work and
you're one step everything from people
everything's food who cares about this
little green piece of paper I don't know
if anyone's going to care about this or
if this is going to be have any buying
power tomorrow right money money also
has the same thing where the the only
attribute that matters is belief in its
value and and banks have the same thing
it's belief in the safety there and
where'd the money come where'd the money
come from though you didn't answer that
um yeah the FDIC is basically is funded
by other Banks so um think of it as an
insurance fund and Banks pay a premium
to that fund and the FDIC Insurance Fund
has a hundred billion dollars in uh fees
that it's collected from Banks and in
fact um in the Federal Reserve letter
that they printed they released
yesterday they said any other fees any
other money that we need is going to
come from a special assessment of other
Banks oh wow so they had this money and
they said we're gonna make up to this
much available not just the Silicon
Valley Bank but any bank that
um that needs a loan against their their
other like their long-term assets if
they have the same kind of duration
mismatch where they have yeah they own
like they're good for the money they
just can't get it out today it's in 30
years they'll have enough money
um for sure it's just that today the the
value of that mortgage that they owned
uh you know had gone down 30 or whatever
yeah that's right they said we'll give
you a loan against that asset uh in the
meantime who are the uh who are the
winners here
um to me the winners are other Community
Banks and other banks that have this
problem so yesterday that uh the
government announced this new brand new
program on like uh one sheet of paper it
was like a Google doc I saw it uh yeah
yeah it's so funny that they uh released
stuff in the way that they do they
create a new program called the bank
term funding program and that's
basically going to prevent the Silicon
Valley Bank problem that they had with
the long duration bonds so basically
Silicon Valley Bank had a 1.8 billion
dollar loss because they sold a bunch of
luck 10-year duration bonds and uh they
have to sell them on for 70 cents on the
dollar
and what the FED announced is that if
you're a bank and you've got a bunch of
10-year paper that's worth 70 cents on
the dollar
you could get a loan from us for all of
it you can get a hundred uh you can get
dollar for Dollar Loan so if you've got
98 billion dollars of 10-year paper
that's now worth 60 billion dollars we
will give you a loan for 90 billion
dollars so that you can uh
not have this problem yeah you can
basically not have liquidity problem and
then the other winners were like there's
a lot of like startup Banks like Mercury
it seems like they were just like
crushing it uh I think brex was another
one like they're just killing it right
well I think the the best thing for them
so I think the real winners is First
Republic because they would have been
wiped out today probably and many others
like First Republic so they got you know
the bullet just whizzed past their ear
and uh you know luckily that was the
last bullet and now there's no more
bullets coming today and there's 2 000
Community Banks in America and so like
all a bunch of those would have had a
bank run
today or this week if they didn't do
what they did Mercury and a bunch of
these other startup Banks basically when
everyone needed to move out of Silicon
Valley Bank it's like who's the fastest
what's the next Bank name I know that I
can open up an account now
um and mercury and others were
beneficiaries of that now they got
billions of dollars billions and
billions of dollars of inflows yesterday
or sorry Friday now
I think that a lot of that would have
skipped town this week so I think they
would have been a middleman because who
the hell is going to keep their money in
a startup Bank
um when this is your fear you're not
going to keep 10 million dollars or 20
million you might have moved it there
just because you needed a quick Safe
Haven but you weren't going to move in
there you were going to still next week
go to Chase or Wells Fargo or whatever
and go put the bulk of the money there
so now I think they're uh in much better
shape because instead of being just a
middleman they might keep a lot more of
that that depositor uh you know those
depository relationships now and is it
possible that other than the equity
holders and the people directly impacted
by this that just like the average
American might be impacted positively by
this in the next six to 12 months
because maybe the FED won't be doing
more rate uh increases so then you know
maybe you can get a mortgage in for four
and a half percent or four percent in
six or twelve months because the you
know the government is like oh hey we
kind of like achieved our mission
because these guys screwed up uh like
inflation might not be as bad now
because of of this big loss is that
accurate or is that too much of a reach
I personally think that's too much of
reach I definitely see people saying
that on Twitter and CNBC but I think
inflation is uh rampant and is has
nothing to do with the Silicon Valley
Bank problem and basically in two weeks
people will have forgotten
Silicon Valley Bank problem and they'll
have all they have all their money as of
today
um so like it's back to businesses as
usual and business as usual still has
massive inflation
and the FED is going to continue to
raise rates in my opinion I this showed
me how naive I am because
I was under the impression that if I
kept a bunch of cash in the bank that
was me doing the safe thing I wasn't
investing this money or trying to get
yield on it I was saying look you know I
just want to keep this in the bank so
that you know just in case and the the
250k FDIC thing was this like idea that
existed I had never heard it ever coming
to play like in 2008 I was a sophomore
in college like I didn't care or no I
didn't have a bank account you know like
I didn't do anything at that time yeah
you thought Lehman Brothers was where
you like buy khaki pants
like oh you got that new parent leaving
exactly it was like are they hosting
Thursday this week what's going on so
it's like yeah this is kind of my first
time for this coming into play did you
like because I was like who the hell is
going to take if you have five million
dollars are you really gonna go open up
20 bank accounts each with a 250k limit
like that sounds so inconvenient I think
that's what a lot of people do but yeah
to be honest does this uh Giannis Greek
Freak announced that he has 50 bank
accounts at different banks each with up
to 250 000 that's how he kind of secures
against us well I saw Jared Kushner when
he uh when Jared Kushner became whatever
his role was in the government what
secretary I forget what he was but he uh
had a release like his his income and I
remember or his his net worth and I
remember looking through it all and he
had dozens of bank accounts and it just
said 250 000 in each account and I was
like why and and this is I mean this
seems is is this normal and I you know
I'm just the only guy who didn't do this
I had to try not to go above too much
above 250 000 but for my business I did
but personally no I try not to go above
250. so you spread it across you know
how many accounts exactly then Sam what
would that be
yeah this is our new way to trick people
into telling us they're they're like
what they're worth be like you're an
FDIC right right
yeah I was surprised that Giannis only
has 50 Banks I was like no because that
story is from his rookie year so he came
over from Greece where Greece was like
having the banking crisis and yeah and
so that was his rookie year that that
his he he and his agent did that now
he's worth like 200 million dollars
there's no way he could be doing that at
this point he's got some other you know
but rich people have this right like if
you're at JP Morgan and you got 20
million plus they'll do an auto like
sweep into a bunch of accounts for you I
think
um I'm not sure exactly how it works but
I'm pretty sure there are there are
products that exist that will do this
they just seem Niche to me and seemed
like I don't know a tool for the
paranoid it didn't seem like a thing
that uh
um I needed to worry about personally
yeah it's so funny because
um my father you know immigrant to the
U.S uh always worried about the banking
system and the US dollar is always like
let's go buy gold bars and bury them
under the house
uh just so that we know that our money
is secured and then he's also like let's
go open bank accounts in Swiss banks
because those are the safe Banks and
they're not going to have this problem
um because those also don't do
fractional Reserve right like a Swiss
bank is I think one for one
um they don't they don't keep you know
just a fraction of your cash in the bank
what's an example of a Swiss bank and
how do you I mean I've only seen like
Wolf of Wall Street where they like go
to Switzerland with like cash in hand is
that that's not actually how you do that
I mean how do you open a specific I
don't even know how you would open a
Swiss account um you know I think Credit
Suisse is uh actually a Swiss bank but
it also has a bunch of
um was seen as as dangerous for a while
I don't even know the name of a Swiss
bank um but I bet you can just open a
bank account online and wire the money
without having to attach uh cash to
Margot Robbie and send her to
Switzerland but that would be cool if
you could
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is CRM
shares its data
right application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
all right we I think we we did a good
job covering the Silicon Valley Bank but
surely you actually had a few other
things that I thought were interesting
one of them being the uh all birds right
what a [__] company man they are really
it's not working out for them is it yeah
all birds is uh in my opinion the
ugliest [__] shoe I've ever seen in
my life and I remember seeing these um
like five to seven years ago in Silicon
Valley all the Venture investors that I
knew were wearing them around town and I
was like you you are ugly your shoe is
ugly you're ugly this sucks this is not
a good looking shoe
and I've heard I saw this tweet that I
think is the best way to describe it all
birds socially acceptable sweatpants for
your feet
yeah I'm not a big fan of them either
but basically they've raised uh two or
three hundred million dollars in in
funding they've done 300 million dollars
in Revenue market cap is uh down from 4
billion to 200 million is that right
it's 200 million right now yep yeah down
95 from their IPO in November of 2021.
how much of the founders do you think
how much they own
um I didn't look at how much the
founders owned I bet they owned a lot of
it before uh when it went public and I
didn't look at you know kind of how much
have they sold off but I got a decent
amount so what's gonna happen with that
um so I think that uh
you know the the problem that they've
been having is that their revenue is
shrinking
um and their costs are really high
they've opened up a ton of stores like
58 stores in the US and abroad and I
think that store strategy isn't working
because not enough people know what all
birds are and walk into the stores and
want some
um
so they've they decide they're going to
stop opening stores they're only going
to open three more stores this year and
those are places where they've already
signed leases they're going to stop any
International growth by they're not
going to open any more international
stores they're gonna uh just do just
fine Distributors internationally to try
to grow they're trying to contain costs
by their manufactured today in New
Zealand they're going to stop
manufacturing them in New Zealand and
move it to one place in Vietnam
um
so you know my sense of what's going to
happen to all birds is uh there's
somebody we're here to bring your own
laces from now on
like they're like cutting every corner
here there's like you know we don't have
running water in the office today uh
we're doing that every every other day
and until this thing is profitable silly
what do you think of this in terms of
like d to C so like I think people have
basically I think DDC got hot people
started a bunch of Brands a bunch of
investors came in and funded these
companies like they were tech companies
but they weren't tech companies Casper
um all birds and then some like Warby
Parker and others that that got BR that
broke out and then you know so on one
hand if I if that's all I knew if I was
just sitting from afar I would have been
like this space doesn't make sense then
and now it's playing out where it's like
yeah these companies are not profitable
they're not doing that well
um you know I think they're burning 100
million dollars a year or something like
that like they're just they're very
mature companies that are still losing a
ton of money and I would have just my
opinion would have just been that but
you and your brother
like your brother built native deodorant
um it was a profit you know basically
raised almost no money uh what did he
raise like 500 grand for that business
is that is that all he ever like 500 000
yep raised 500 000 built it up basically
by himself with like you know a very
very small lean team you know packing
deodorant like you know at their kitchen
table at your kitchen table in your
apartment and sold that thing for 100
million dollars when it was highly
profitable
um that whole way
you know then you have that model and
you've had a you know you we don't talk
too much about your business but you've
been involved in a very different style
of d2c that is highly profitable lean
and mean raise zero capital or very
minimal capital and I feel like nobody
even knows about those businesses those
are like you know more under the radar
everybody only hears about the big VC
ones uh you know like away luggage and
stuff like that what what is your take
are you sort of like
that other way is dumb or are they
actually just two different games and
you know both both are valid yeah I
think there are two different games the
native Playbook of Rey's little Capital
um focus on profitability acquired
customers uh so that your break even on
the first purchase of profitable on the
first purchase and uh scale through
repeat purchases that are generating a
ton of profit using that
to either reinvest in the business to
launch new products or just take
distributions
um so I think that's a super valid
Playbook and I think there is a valid
approach to the raise a bunch of venture
capital and try to build
um
a business at a much larger scale
um who's doing that that you think that
they have a good shot yeah maybe
um yeah figs in my opinion is a great
example because uh
they're like one of the problems with
all birds is they're a fashion brand and
at some point the World Turns against
you and
um like I believe that all birds are
ugly I think other people are gonna
arrive at a similar conclusion at some
point and then all birds is gonna have
to find the next style to get to that
place uh to to kind of continue to
succeed
um figs is basically a uniform so uh it
doesn't need to be better looking over
time yeah but that's a bullsh I think
you're wrong there I think that I think
that that strategy is not bad like look
at Louis Vuitton you know they've been
around for 300 years and it's always
been cool I think that their execution
they just picked a lame thing yeah I
don't think I don't think it's a bad
strategy I think they just it's a stupid
shoe or at least that's what that's what
a lot of people think
yeah I mean Nike is a great example of a
business that um
has scaled to you know more than a a
hundred billion market cap I want to say
and uh they're a fashion brand that
serves um you know the super high end as
well as the low end
um so that they figure out how to do it
so I think there is a Playbook to go
raise Venture money
um or private Equity money and get to
scale
um I just think a lot of the of the
companies that have raised money have
been undisciplined they've hired too
many people like Grove collaborative
um what do they do Grove collaborative
is a San francisco-based startup that's
10 years old it's also publicly traded
they started out being this Marketplace
of kind of natural products so I've saw
them as
um I would see ads for them saying get
free Mrs Meyers
uh kit
and I would click on those ads because I
was like free stuff sign me up and
they're basically trying to give you um
get you involved in a get you enrolled
in a subscription of buying a bunch of
Home Products got it okay
cool idea cool idea yeah great idea and
it went public through us back and it
has the same problem as all birds and
Away luggage although way is private
um growth collaborative stock is down 96
percent and has a market cap of 70
million dollars it's worth
uh you know way less than the cash that
they've raised that's crazy yeah and the
stock is sub one dollars if they have to
do a reverse stock split to avoid being
delisted
and uh yeah they basically have to fire
a bunch of people and uh stop spending
as much money on marketing
so that they can be profitable
and have they basically have to accept
declining Revenue to get to
profitability and uh that's what growth
collaborative just did in the third
quarter of last year it was their first
profitable quarter ever
so what companies do you like
they're saying all the companies you hey
on here you have wish you have Grove
you've talked about all birds uh you
don't like box yeah which is like Costco
online yeah what do you like
um I think there's a bunch of companies
that are uh awesome businesses that are
worth less than they were in March of
um so they're trading at less than
pre-covered valuations and I love those
companies but uh some of them are the
ones you hear about all the time which
is uh Facebook Amazon I think those are
two great businesses
you and I were walking in in SoHo in New
York and after some Meetup and I uh I
won't say the amount you can say the
amount if you want but you said I just
bought blank amount of stock in
Squarespace and my jaw like kind of
dropped I was like what did you really
why and you like told me how much you
love that company and it was a very
large amount
um and so are you still at the
Squarespace uh yeah I bought a million
dollars of Squarespace stock I still own
it I don't know if I made any money on
it I at some point it turned into like
250 000 because uh Squarespace stock
went down so I'd lost 750 000 but I
think it has since turned around
um you know it's up 15 year-to-date
um I think Squarespace is super
undervalued as a business but I'm not
sure it's a great stock to buy
uh
you have like a long history with
Squarespace let me ask you a different
different question
um at one point you tweeted out
something like
hey if we you know if a guy happened to
have 50 million liquid and wanted to
double it
um you know what's your best idea and
you got like a hundred replies I
remember going through them and being
pretty unimpressed with most of the
ideas it didn't seem like I I thought
you know you some some great stuff would
come out of there but but maybe in
something like this 100 people reply and
it's really three interesting ideas did
you get anything interesting or what did
people say when you tweeted that out and
did you get any interesting ideas on
what to do with your money from that
um I got one interesting idea which was
uh try to go buy all of wish or you know
51 of wish
um wish has 700 million dollars in cash
and its market cap is 286 million so
it's trading at less than cash
um
so you know buy enough stock that you
can uh convince management to distribute
the stock distribute the cash and shut
the company down
right and can you and I remember seeing
that uh why doesn't that happen in
practice right companies got 700 million
in cash it's trading at 300 million uh
why doesn't you know it seems like the
the the the like the video game move is
you buy the 300 million dollar company
you shut it down tomorrow so it stops
burning cash and you distribute 700
million out you profited 400 million why
doesn't that happen in practice or does
it happen in practice uh so there are
people like Bill Ackman Carl Icahn that
are activist investors that do this kind
of thing um you know they do it with
apple even uh Netflix like call icon
uh will basically go by five percent of
a company and then call up management
and say hey we want you to do X Y and Z
and if you don't we're gonna just keep
being a thorn in your side
um
and so and we're going to try to remove
your board directors and put our board
directors in uh we're gonna threaten to
fire youseo they do a bunch of this kind
of stuff
um and generally what will happen is the
CEOs will just listen to Carl Icahn and
do what he says or do something else
that makes their stock price go up 10 15
20 percent that
um and then Carl Icahn will sell his
position make billions of dollars and be
like great that was fun
um
with something like wish uh it's
if you try to go buy a wish stock it's
so thinly traded that you would
basically Drive the price up and you
would never be able to buy 51 you'd have
to you'd have to pay you know 100
700 million 800 million dollar market
cap to basically own 51 of it dude it
seems like most of the companies that
you've mentioned or a lot many of the
companies you mentioned went public via
SPAC has there been once back that has
worked out
uh that is a great question I have no
idea and for the like I remember chamoth
was all about spec I don't pay attention
to the public market so I'm a little I'm
definitely out of my depth here but I
know enough to know that he was big on
specs what are these guys what's their
reputation right now which is
they got and did they make money they
made money at going up making it happen
and so now are they just like
oh [__] y'all like you know what I mean
like are they just like uh they don't
care
yeah the way this backs work is if
you're the sponsor which is what your
mouth was and a bunch of these like he
took Open Door public
um through SPAC uh Sofi public thrifts
back you end up getting a percentage of
the company without taking any real risk
um
so chamath has made out like a bandit in
I think he's done five to ten spacks
he's made money in each one of those
specs and I think every uh how much
um more than a billion dollars across
all of those for sure
wow and so how does the math work so I
remember I think I'd heard one point you
have to put up three percent of the
capital to own but you own 20 of the
company when it goes public is that
right or did I did I misunderstand
um yeah I don't remember the math but
it's something along those lines which
is for taking the company public you get
um it's probably not 17 but you get
something like five percent or ten
percent of the company's stock for
basically taking it public and you don't
take any risk you basically raise money
from a bunch of Institutions
um you hold that money for up to 18
months you have 18 months to find a
Target that you want to take public you
find a Target you make a deal with them
to take them public
um all those investors that have gave
you money 18 months ago
they can either keep their money in the
deal or uh sell it and get their ten
dollars back
um
and so a bunch of people will sell
because they're like oh this isn't going
to work sell I want to sell my stock so
oftentimes
um the SPAC which is publicly traded
will be trading at ten dollars and then
it'll get and the target will get
announced we're gonna
um take uh Grove collaborative public
and then the stock will drop immediately
when uh the target gets announced
because everyone is selling and it's
like oh this isn't gonna this isn't a
good Target so what's his reputation
then I mean is or is he just like so I
mean so original give a [__] about his
reputation well did you did you guys say
the thing that's on this dock which was
uh the reverse Robin Hood steal from the
poor and give to make himself Rich no no
yeah I was waiting for you because I
know I don't I mean I don't know enough
to know about him and Michael schnick
but Sean you have a strong opinion about
it
uh I mean I want to hear Stewie's
opinion I don't think I have a that
strong opinion
yeah you give them a hard time dude you
give them a really hard time
you know I think chimath is super smart
super successful I love his uh you know
those cashmere sweaters that he wears on
all in podcast they look dope I gotta
buy me some
um
but what he's done with the spax is
literally the opposite of Robin Hood
he's stolen from the poor and given to
himself and uh I'm surprised that his
reputation is not tarnished in the
public markets or in what is it can you
ask your question is it that he ended up
you know dumping on retail because it
was always designed it was kind of
designed that way it was gonna be that
way or oh well the Market's just turned
and everything's down you know like I I
don't fault Jeff Bezos because my Amazon
stock is down you know like that's out
of their control it's a good business
blah blah blah versus
no the way these were set up it was a
bit of a house of cards you know um he
was gonna make money and at some point
this was going to happen because these
fundamentally didn't make sense which
one which one is it more yeah you're
asking is the what's the intention yeah
do you think do you think he knew and
that the intention was yeah this is
probably how it's gonna play out but
let's just see
um to me these are pump and dump schemes
uh like in Wolf of Wall Street
if the company is sound and uh gonna go
public generally the companies will go
public on their own uh using the
traditional IPO path or a direct listing
um you know that's what Squarespace
Spotify slack all these companies that
went public during the same era that he
was doing these specs the companies that
go public through specs are trying to
rush to get public and it's not the
airbnbs of the world it's the Grove
collaboratives of the world and so fives
of the world that are doing it
um businesses that that are not as sound
now what they would say was like the
very first one I think he did was virgin
and it was look this is a company that
you'd have to be a rule like you know
Tech investor to understand it's got a
really long-term huge vision and you
know they needed somebody who believed
and they didn't want to you know take
their chances with the with the
short-term minded stock you know uh you
know IPO stock market so some version of
that was like you had to be a True
Believer in Technology Innovation and
you had to be smart enough to understand
how big this business could be that's
why I'm taking it public and so it kind
of made sense on the first one
and then pretty soon it was like just
putting lipstick on the pig and selling
it and that's how it felt to me at least
and so I'm kind of of the same opinion
which is I think obviously he's smart
and obviously he's successful I don't
think those are arguable I think that uh
he's also very pompous you know I don't
love his personality I also think that
what he did with the specs I think you
know uh seems to be more like like more
like the pump and dub or uh putting
lipstick on a pig like you know these
weren't great businesses it was what can
I do to just you know
to get something to to cash here
um because he again he had a free role
in a lot of these exactly and so you
know and I and I find him to be you know
somewhat disingenuous when he when he
talks like you know I remember before he
took Metro mile public it was uh Buffett
had Geico I have Metro Mile and here's
why it's better blah blah blah fast
forward like less than a year at Metro
mile is you know sold for 30 cents on
the dollar to Lemonade
um because it was whatever not in good
shape at that time
um and then you know no mention of it
ever again you know it's like oh yeah on
to the next
yeah the the thing um you know there's a
bunch of people that were uh pumping
Bitcoin or other crypto products and
when they tweet there's a ton of people
that reply to their tweets saying [__]
you I lost my life savings because of
your um because I took your financial
advice when chamath tweets I look to see
what the responses are there aren't many
people that are like hey you screwed uh
all the you know the public moms and
single moms and uh families on uh on
these specs dude I was with your brother
one time silly and we were hanging out
and someone was talking about a get rich
quick scheme and how like uh I think I
someone they were like saying like uh
you know no no one likes to quit get
rich quick scheme and your brother goes
uh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa getting rich
quick is the best way to get rich and uh
and your brother's pretty funny because
sometimes he'll say funny stuff but it's
like oh yeah you're right that is like
that's way better and Sean was talking
about chamoth and virgin he's like you
know we don't care about the short term
it's for the long term and a lot of
times when I when I read about this
these uh public markets and they talk
about long term I'm like
yeah I think you're I I kind of care
about the short term I definitely care
about the short term a bit too uh so and
and they like use that word long term to
uh disguise like bad [__] like you know
it's about the long term it's not about
the short term just hold it's the long
term I'm like I don't know getting rich
quick and in a short amount of time
that's that sounds nice too uh I would
like it not to fail in the short term uh
that would be nice there there's this
Warren Buffett quote where uh somebody
is like some reporter is like hey what
you talk about is pretty
um simple and sounds like anyone can do
it uh why aren't more people applying
the Warren Buffett strategy and and
becoming billionaires and his response
was everyone wants to get rich quickly
I'm about getting rich slowly and nobody
has the patience to do it yeah but
here's my issue with that when he talks
about that he keeps talking about the
long term and he's 95. uh it's like bro
there there ain't a long term have some
fun yeah you don't have long term
anymore stop talking about long term
maybe long term stops when you're 60.
it's like enjoy it yeah I was talking to
these um 25 year olds and I was like
two million dollars when you're 25 is
more valuable than 20 million dollars
when you're 45. because you can
basically do awesome stuff at 25 that
you're not going to be able to do at 45.
yeah dude I agree I agree
um Sean what are you gonna say I was
gonna say uh you had shared this blog
post about a good a good quest which is
uh I think a guy from Founders fun I
think wrote it a while a while back I
remember reading at me like this is
actually pretty interesting
um
seem like something that maybe maybe
resonated with you can you explain the
idea of a good Quest and then I want to
hear you guys uh talk about it
um yeah it's kind of like this guy
basically was like
um
some guy found responders Stevens I
think
um he was basically like a bunch of the
brightest Minds in Silicon Valley and in
America and in the world are uh focused
on bad quests so kind of in a game you
can uh in the game of life you're either
focused on something that is noble and
honorable and makes the world a better
place or in his language you're focused
on
um
short-term things that are going to make
you rich quickly uh even if they're
incremental improvements um so a
slightly better mouse trap
and he basically is like there is no uh
we're wasting society and
um people are wasting their energy
brilliant people are wasting their
Brilliance on dumb problems and we
should be trying to solve the greatest
problems that we have in our lifetimes
and that is the noble work and
everything else is [__]
and he points out he's like most I don't
know man but this guy look but do our
Pro his former job he he used to work at
Mike's Hard Lemonade I don't know if I
can trust this guy
did you really that's how he knows dude
that's the experience he did the total
opposite he works at Andrew a defense
company but
like I don't know
I prefer Nerf like
sorry go ahead I'm an idiot yeah he's a
co-founder of mandrel
so he points out this thing which is
like you know the average person is not
capable of
going on one of these good quests so if
you're brilliant if you really are in
that kind of like top one percent of
talent uh and motivation and ability
it's kind of like your moral imperative
like you you kind of got to be the ones
doing this because who else if not you
then who
um is sort of the the mindset that he
has
um and so I would say that like
you know
I think you're awesome but you you
yourself are like I want to go in a good
question you've been telling me this for
like five years yes and you're like I've
spent my whole life building these like
mouse traps that make a bunch of money
because I just wait for them I just see
them they're obvious this widget I could
sell this widget and make a bunch of
money
um and you've done that are you did this
blog post tip you over the edge to do a
good Quest or did it have the opposite
effect and turn you off and say actually
you know F this guy and F this whole
like noble Quest [__] maybe next
week
[Laughter]
um you know I went to this uh SV Angel
Event in San Francisco last week
um and I'd been to San Francisco in a
really long time because I was having
this like existential question myself of
uh should I be going on good and hard
quests versus easy quests
um
and you know easy quests are great
because you have a great quality of life
like uh you don't work that hard
um you can go play tennis in the middle
of the day or work out at noon like my
brother every day at noon will go work
out for two hours in the middle of the
day
um we could have a sick pad in in New
York and maybe a place in La and and
travel all over the place I mean you
guys have a pretty nice life yeah yeah
like he's gonna go to Japan uh next week
um just for fun to look at uh go to the
Cherry Blossom Festival
um so you know he's uh
it's very easy to be seduced by like
quality of life and easy quests in my
opinion I like how you're using your
brother here instead of yourself you do
all the same things you're just like
yeah using him as like this guy it's way
easier to use him uh than kind of look
at the mirror look in the mirror more
closely
um and so you know I went to that event
and uh Sam Altman spoke and he was
basically like
um everyone thinks open AIS and
overnight success I've been working on
this for seven years God damn it and so
have all of these other AI
um scientists and AI engineers and it
took us seven years to make chat GPT
what it is today that's not that long
it's not that long but uh it's it's a
really long time
like basically they didn't launch a
product for maybe five years or
something along those lines
um and you know he had every Quest at
his disposal he could have just simply
sat back and Angel invested and done you
know
become you know as proficient at
pickleball as one can be right like he
had he was running YC at the time and he
left probably you know the the best job
in Silicon Valley which is running YC
yeah probably the highest paid lowest
effort job you could have like it's up
to you how hard you want to work there
but exposure to new people new
entrepreneurs new ideas you get to do
all the fun [__] you get to see all the
smartest people you get to be the king
maker uh you know you have the infinite
money glitch if you're her if you're
doing everyone in Silicon Valley is
coming to kiss your ring hey quick to go
do this non-profit AI thing and I
remember at the time I remember
literally at the time this was like what
did he do this like 2016 or 2019 or
something like that he he left he had
been funding it as his own like you know
personal passion project basically until
then that he left YC to do that and I
remember thinking at the time
I should probably just go follow Sam
Altman like if he is gonna do this with
his time there's really no better signal
in the world that that's this is like
the right place to be unfortunately I
didn't act on that but I remember having
that thought in back in you know 2018
2019. yeah it's it's funny to me that
you say that like seven years is not a
long time
um because yeah I guess in a sense it's
not but
um
seven years at the same time seems like
Infinity
um when you're working on uh a startup
and you're there's no immediate
gratification like I can't think of the
last time I was able to work on
something for seven years without some
form of immediate gratification I mean
there was there was there was Milestones
uh look at this guy the did Trey Stevens
who started Android like funding rounds
winning certain contracts some type of
press I mean that's like pretty cool you
know there you got you can get yourself
you can get your dopamine hit but what
are you gonna do are you gonna quit
doing this small boy [__] that makes a
lot of money you're gonna start doing
something like legitimate that like
actually matches your IQ
um yeah I want to try and do a hard
Quest but what what's what's the what
are the handful of ideas or industries
that uh tickle your fancy
and then doing something in healthcare
would be really amazing and
transformative
um
I I think healthcare in America is so
bad uh it's shocking to me like
um you know my mom had a bunch of
medical problems last year and just
getting access to doctors uh is insane
um like if you want to get see a
specialist you have to wait 60 or 90
days to go see a specialist specialized
doctor
and um a friend of mine who's a doctor
was like here's how you solve this
here's the concierge uh medicine
practice you give them 30 000 a year
yeah I had one it was 25 Grand a year
yeah you pay them 25 Grand 30 grand a
year or whatever it is and all they do
is they are able to get you appointments
faster because they're able to text the
doctors because they know the doctors
personally because they used to work
with them and say hey can you do me a
favor I'll see my guy uh next week
instead of three months from now
um it's kind of like gangster a little
bit like it's like uh it's like the
doctors are it's run by the streets you
know what I mean
it is pretty weird it's not cool yeah
it's not cool it's broken and then the
other really [__] up thing is
um if you have a medical problem and a
neurologist will be like this is a
cardiac cardiologist problem and the
cardiologist will be like this is a
neurologist problem and the two of them
are like Superman and Clark Kent which
is they're never in the same room at the
same [__] time so you can't actually
get real information about what the
problem is and they never talk to each
other they talk to each other through
like handwritten notes uh in the dark of
night
do you have a tangible idea on this or
you're just like healthcare it's like
healthcare is just too big of a word
doesn't mean anything
yeah it is too big of a word one idea
that I've been taking around with is
um like remote monitoring of patients so
uh you know my mom um lives in Dallas
um sometimes there sometimes traveling
and
um
I want to have some device that she has
that is like monitoring her blood
pressure
[Music]
um her blood sugar her heart rate and uh
reporting that to me and to all these
other doctors in um you know real time
so that if there's a problem you know it
faster
and so that you can go track this stuff
right now when you go to the doctor and
if you have blood sugar problems or um
high blood pressure problems they're
like what was your blood pressure last
week versus what is it right now what
was your blood sugar last week versus
what it is right now that it's always
reported uh yeah it's always wrong yeah
it's self-reported and
um it's just so broken and I think being
able to track this stuff in a more
automated seamless seamless way device
yeah like I got a whoop and uh you know
that's doing some extra tracking but
yeah some kind of embedded device that's
like continuous glucose monitor plus
um some way to measure your blood
pressure and uh kind of keep in one one
place
um the other thing that I think is a
really interesting idea is that I went
to Georgia Tech in 2003 and at the time
they were working on building a smart
home and one of the ideas they had for a
smart home was a smart toilet so imagine
when you're using the toilet every time
you use the toilet it texts you and says
dude uh you're eating too many French
fries
right stop dual sample basically yeah
stool and urine sample and uh are
measuring in real time what's up wasn't
there a company that was doing that in
San Francisco that was totally a fraud
was it you biome is that what they were
doing it wasn't a smart toilet though I
think you had to send it to them
uh okay wow [__] that that's that's kind
of weird right I can't even how do you
get a well I don't know but uh no those
are interesting I've seen people like
tinkering around with this idea I do
think it's very fascinating I have no
idea how you do it what do you [__]
a net and it like takes a little strain
uh I don't know I don't know what the
mechanics are but I think it's an
interesting idea that like let's put it
let me ask you a different way I think
you have a very good way of thinking
about
problems and what I mean by that is
um
every time I've come to you with an idea
like two things happen that that are
different with you than with most people
one is you're like
I'm not you don't sit there and ask like
uh is this feasible or how would we do
it you know like that question comes
later it's like first let me decide on
like the big idea and you know how how
could you know would this be amazing if
it happened okay then I'll go find a way
to make it happen or like you know your
brother when he started the deodorant
company I remember somebody was like
boys do you know anything about
deodorant he's like no I know nothing
about deodorant but in six months I
don't know everything there is to know
about deodorant and sure enough you know
built a very big dinner man so like the
kind of like not being limited by what I
know today is like you know I would say
one factor and the other is like
um you're not one at least from what I
could tell like you don't really
consider like plan B's or like if this
fails or why would this fail uh you I
remember when we started a thing
together you were like yeah I just I was
trying to do that and you were like I
don't know man I don't really think that
way I just sort of uh I decide to win
and then I do it and I just plan to win
and I don't really focus on the rest am
I am I correctly understanding that or
no
um yeah I think I think starting with
um
starting with is if can this work and uh
or like you know what are so many people
when they're evaluating an idea uh
immediately are like no this is not
gonna work for reason X Y and Z actually
my brother is like this
um and so I hate talking to him about
new ideas because he's always just like
[__] on them he's just kind of a
skeptic by Nature
um
so I definitely start with the uh if
this works uh what does the world look
like and uh
uh can this be a big deal if it actually
works
um so when I think about the smart
toilet I'm like cool uh right now to
figure out if you have colon cancer they
do uh you have to poop in an envelope
and send it to a lab
um what happens if this is automated
um
right now uh
like there's all these medical things
that I should probably be doing
differently I just have no idea what
they are and even if I knew them I
didn't I don't have a good way to like
have somebody enforce it in a automated
way
um if that happened across America we
could solve diabetes because oftentimes
diabetes is a disease that you choose
instead of a disease that
um you're forced with
um
so yeah definitely start with the if
this works is it going to be a big deal
and then
um
then I'm kind of like cool could I get
customers for this and if I could then
I'm kind of like that's all you really
need to start you don't really need an
any more information about like
how to build a toilet or
um any of the science like I think you
can figure that out later
but can this be big would this be big if
it worked and can I get customers yeah
yeah
those are the two and often what you
know one thing that happens I look at a
lot of startup like investment deals
with sui and uh it'll be like here's
these great people there's this great
technology great product blah blah and
he'll just be like cool so how are you
gonna get customers and like you you'd
think like
this like appears to be like a baffling
question to so many Founders or they'll
say something and he'll be like okay so
what do you mean so what do you mean
like what are you where are you gonna go
or like you know have you done that
um
tell me about three times in your life
that you've done that and uh and then
he's sort of like you know I'm in or out
based on their ability to get customers
and I think yeah it's like the I told
you that my meme of the year is that
midwit Meme it's like the genius and the
idiot the way they think it's aligned
and the analyzer who's taking into
account 75 variables actually ends up
with the wrong answer more often than
not and like this idea of like
can it be you know if it worked would it
be big and can I get customers is the
sort of the midwit meme like you know in
real life
yeah I don't think you need to know more
than that in fact um Sam and I were on
this call where this guy was pitching uh
I think it's the company was called
Firefly it was pitching
um
ads on top of Ubers and taxi cabs in uh
like this physical device that was on
top of the and they're around now but I
think at the time he wanted a hundred
million dollar or maybe 60 million
dollar valuation and uh it was crazy I
remember being off that call and I was
like huh yeah Sam messaged me and was
like this is bananas can you believe
this guy uh this guy's valuation and the
audacity
um and he was uh I think at the time
losing money
um on each individual device for years
um
so yeah there are there are often times
where people I I'm shocked by how many
people are like cool I figured out what
the product is but I have no idea how to
get customers I have no idea what the
economics of that looked like and that's
where companies go to die
um how'd that company end up by the way
did it did it do it it still exists but
I have no idea got it
um I'm drinking the water this water
here this is a 25 bottle of water
because it's like pure water that's been
filtered
um it I'm in LA right now it turns out
that if you drink tap water in La
supposedly according to this guy it has
Pharmaceuticals in the water without
Irwin or something yeah I think this
instrument one and uh
this water is basically uh pure in a way
that like you can't get water anywhere
else these days
and so it costs 25 a bottle this is
insane and it tastes just like water
and you're pointing it so it's a yeah so
you know super interesting idea
um I I didn't talk to this guy or
anything but um I wonder what their
distribution strategy is uh because I
think putting 25 water at irwan or Whole
Foods is like an inadequate distribution
strategy to get the meaningful skill for
this well I'll give you the counter
example I was doing some research on the
milk boys
um who and I won't do the full thing
about the novel Boys in their kind of
business Empire but one thing that stood
out was I was watching this clip and it
was John Shahidi who you guys might know
because he's like kind of came he was
like in Silicon Valley then he
transitioned into like Hollywood
influencer stuff when he had his like
mobile app shots get popular from like a
bunch of fine stars is John their
manager and he's now their manager so
like shots didn't work out he didn't
build the next Snapchat uh even though
he had every influencer and Justin
Bieber and Floyd Mayweather and like all
these people using it and investing in
him but he was like cool I can help
these influencers out so he started
managing influencers and now he just is
the manager of the note boys and they
were like so they're there's hard
Seltzer brand happy Dad which is
basically like it looks literally like a
Bud Light uh like just like it looks
like the right product it's towards the
right market and
um they value the company I think at 250
million dollars right now they're doing
like
I forgot how much uh exactly I'll pull
it up it's getting close to 100 million
in Revenue yeah it's close to 100
million in Revenue so somewhere between
50 and 100 million in Revenue uh so the
brand is doing really well and it's very
young it's like it's like a very new
um brand but
um
they were like oh so for happy Dad like
you know what's what's the next product
are you coming out with a new flavor or
like a hard alcohol like what do you get
to do because
no we have basically Futsal we've done
all the hard work to get foot soldiers
to get into gas stations 7-Elevens and
whatever and so rather than compete with
ourselves and like the fiercest
competition in the drink Market in those
we just looked around the store we just
sent people into the stores that were
like doing these like gas station sales
for us and they looked around and were
like what's the easiest category we can
win and they're like so we're doing uh
beef jerky they're like beef jerky is
like a really stale category we already
have this distribution channel into
these uh gas stations and stuff in
convenience stores like hundreds if not
thousands of these stores across the
country that is The Edge all we have to
do is work backwards from that like we
have the we have the front end sales now
we just need to figure out the back end
product that should go into that into
that sales Channel and when I hear that
I'm like the milk boys run a more
sophisticated business operation than
like 95 of Silicon Valley in just that
one way of thinking yeah it's amazing um
yeah there's this Justin Quan Khan quote
uh first-time Founders are obsessed with
products second time Founders are
obsessed with distribution
now I think there's this uh concept of
um I just focused on distribution the
product comes after I have distribution
yeah that's what like what we did with
the audience right it's like cool I'm
gonna build up a big podcast we didn't
sort of intentionally go about it this
way we just wanted to do a podcast but
once you realize oh cool I could just
build up a huge audience I can come up
with great products after uh I don't
even need to like know what product it
would be going in
yeah I didn't understand that with the
hustle I was like why are you guys
investing and they're like because
building an audience is really hard and
I was like that's not that hard to just
do this this beep up Boop and you got it
and then I kind of later on I realized
that to build an audience that's engaged
it's kind of it is a little formulaic
but it's also a lot of luck and kind of
catching lightning in a bottle where and
then once you have it it's uh very very
very very valuable now that I don't have
it anymore I'm like ah I get it that was
hard
yeah it's amazing to see people all
around uh the world doing this now and
all these verticals like you know Doug
demuro
um did this then uh got an audience then
started cars and bids dude that was
early on Sean I was telling you Doug
tomorrow that that car's in Biz it's
gonna be big now his competitor was just
in the New York Times last week for
selling a billion dollars with the cars
congrats on uh investing on that when
you called it
yeah yeah about that yeah did you try to
invest in Doug Demarest thing uh maybe
like a DM on Twitter was about the
extent of it uh but oh so no it was most
I just it was I talked the talk I didn't
walk the walk and also I didn't have a
lot of money at the time I think he it's
it's about four years old but no I I I
talk to talk that's about all I did it's
also amazing because uh these guys will
um are often bootstrapped right because
they basically start with no audience
they just start making an audience and
then uh once they have an audience
they're generating so much profit from
the audience through YouTube videos or
whatever uh so they don't even need
outside Capital so I think even if you
chase them down he might have been like
I'm already making money I don't need to
raise money
um so it just turns a lot of Silicon
Valley stuff upside down of like you
know distribution first that generates
profit then you use that profit to um
make product silly did you look at the
feedback from your last episode people
loved you they like your voice they say
that you're calming and I agree right
all right I uh I only listen to feedback
that like Sean or Ben Levy texted me you
had very positive feedback people liked
you they said that you're calming that
they would do anything that you'd say
things like that very it got a little
weird
yeah thanks for doing this people thanks
for doing this hopefully uh people
enjoyed the uh Silicon Valley Bank
breakdown and a few other things and uh
if you made it this far we're doing a
meet up actually Sean tomorrow you're
not going to make it we had we have it
like sold out like right away 500 people
but uh we'll be doing another one April
28th ish and we'll announce that more
info on that soon yeah I got one quick
thing I want to plug which is
um you know Sean has this guy who's his
right hand guy who helped him on all
these different projects uh I want to
find a right-hand guy to help me with a
bunch of projects so like source and
diligence Investments
um
of research random business ideas I have
come work for me full time for the next
five or ten years and let's go do
something amazing and what do they find
you
you can find me on Twitter DM me
all right and is your hand what's your
handle it's s-u-l-i it's my full name
s-u-l-e-m-a-n-a-l-i
all right that's good you're one of the
very few people that has taken advantage
of this to actually promote something
but you did it at the end you could have
done in the beginning but that's all
right [__] it only the strong made it
here that's what he filtered about
that's right he filtered out the week
the week people all right we're out of
here that's the pot cool
[Music]